hey hey hey hey hey hey hey hey you look
incredible
you look incredible what are you wearing
first of all dolce gabbana from head to
toe
you know i feel like just hearing your
new single it felt like you channeled
aretha because it had that vibe it took
you back when you hear that you feel
1968. you know what i'm saying do you
hit did you
did you feel that when you recorded it
yes did you feel the church
in it the the spirit the soul you know
i wanted to make sure that was the base
and the premise of everything because
aretha was the gospel you know it felt
like the live recording she did in the
church and that's with that first
30 45 seconds you feel like you're back
in that church and the old cbs news
cameras are rolling
i'm so happy to hear that because that
was my sentiments exactly
being here tonight the culture coming
back together and celebrating black
women
just here to celebrate you know see us
celebrate each other be here on one
accord you know women deserve their
flowers and we do
so much so i'm just honored to be one of
them and in the midst of all these
beautiful women and our culture
we're all waiting in anticipation on
this movie
tell me okay but give me something that
surprised you about doing this
aretha hand picked you no pressure but
she hand picked you
a lot a lot of pressure i everyone is
counting down and i'm like please don't
tell me i don't want to know that's
enough pressure
enough with her saying jennifer do this
but i you know that's that woman power
that's
empowerment like if she passed the torch
if she said jennifer you can do it
that gave me the strength and
encouragement to try
this is kind of mama's night out though
right are you having are you having
mama's night out
it is although i wanted to bring the
babies
they had to go back home we had a blast
before the kids left
i only got one kid but i collect
people's children
so yes tonight is mother's night but we
get to enjoy
ourselves a little bit you look
magnificent enjoy the night
you